[Music]
riley is going to start off this hour in
minneapolis hi riley welcome to the
ramsey show
good afternoon mr ramsey good afternoon
mrs ellis thank you very much for having
me on the show today our honor sir how
many how may we help
uh i just wanted to start by saying
thank you for all that you and your team
do uh we're very fortunate to have you
around here in the united states and uh
all over the world listening to how you
help people
um essentially my absolutely essentially
my question today is uh is this i'm
missing anything i am currently
investing 20 my 401k
through my employer
i'm currently maxing out my roth ira
i am currently doing monthly
distributions
uh to mutual funds as well as a house
fund that i have set up
into into a fidelity 500 index fund
based on the s p 500 index
in addition to a couple more
high dividend yield stocks and i really
just want to ensure that i'm doing
everything i can to set myself up
for the ability to live and give like no
one else in the future
wow i'm gonna be off friday you want to
fill in
i sure wish i had the opportunity
i mean you got this you got this down
dude you got it so dialed in how old did
you say you are
i am 23 years old what do you make
i make between 60 and 70 000 my uh main
job 40 hours a week i'm making just over
61 and then my side house so i do about
15 to 20 hours a week
make 14 an hour plus tips
how did you learn to do all this by the
time you're 23
i had some fantastic leaders growing up
through sports and a father that worked
extremely hard
dropped out of college at 18 has been
working for the same company for 35
years and taught me how to work hard and
be consistent and not be a good person
wow
good for you
pretty amazing welcome
you you're single 23 you make 70 you're
putting all your money in
investments right now and you're saving
towards the house and you're 100 debt
free i don't i don't have anything to
add to this equation you're heading in
the right direction now the next thing
that'll happen usually is you do buy the
house and then we'll be about the
business of getting it paid off as soon
as possible after that
and you know you're gonna and you'll
back your investments down to 15 of your
income at that point until you get that
done but
i don't i don't see any flaws right here
well what's the timeline for when you
want to buy the house what's kind of the
goal you've set for yourself
so i want to move out of my house and
actually move to the nashville area or
somewhere a little warmer from
minneapolis within the next three years
with my company and then
because of the company and the nature of
the business i'm in uh probably be
moving around quite often so i was
thinking renting for the next probably
10 years until i settle down in a place
that i'm going to be longer than five
years and then
get a 15-year mortgage and try to pay it
off in five
yeah so you're thinking about moving in
three years and then buying in ten years
yes now okay so you've got time to save
up that down payment i guess yes ma'am
i currently have a little over 30 000
saved up for the house or renting funds
essentially because i
didn't spend my entire
fund for college i graduated a year
early yeah if you're careful when you
make your move
even if you're not going to be there but
two or three years since you're going to
be paying cash for the property
you may want to look at going and buying
earlier than that 10-year mark but i
mean
somehow i got a feeling this is not
going to unfold exactly the way you've
got it lined out there
you know um
you know you get married it could change
this equation
as an example um like where you land how
often you move what you do all those
kinds of things are affected then so
uh
that's what i would look at but i think
you've got a great start i don't see
anything wrong with the direction you're
going for the next 24 36 months
just keep rocking it man i mean really i
don't have any fixes to this make sure
you're being generous
make sure you're enjoying your money
don't nerd out on every penny
okay so you need to have some enjoyment
and if those are not muscles you use
very often they can get atrophied so
force yourself in your budget i'm going
to blow
this much money
i'm going to be outrageously generous
with this much money
and force yourself into those muscle
groups but um it's not you know it's not
that hard i think you can do it you're
pretty incredible what a rock star 23
years old that's how it's done where did
we find these